das essen das essen ist jetzt ein total
profanes thema aber es ist tatsächlich
das thema mit dem ich gerade komme jeden
tag wir tun ist genau und das holt uns
wieder zurück ins jetzt mich in dem fall
ein bisschen in die
gestern vor kurzer zeit hat nämlich
moderatoren zu mir gesagt du ich habe
hier eine große show die steht an und
soll eigentlich müsste ich hier noch ein
paar kilo und ich meinte nur zu ihr du
machst nicht essen ist ein
feministischer akt es sind tatsächlich
ist empfohlen kann man nicht anders
sagen nur wenn wir unseren körper mit
dem richtigen nährstoffen versorgen dann
sind wir frei kann es aus eigener
erfahrung sagen wenn du nicht isst
kannst du nicht denken in dieser stelle
ist das tatsächlich ein appell diäten
und das wissen wir schon seit langem die
jede machen ja de facto dick und sie
machen ja leider auch dumm und was sie
auch machen ist wir verlieren als frau
das vertrauen in unsere eigene körper
intelligenz und unser körper als frau
ist leider leider ist zum glück das
intelligenteste was wir hier und ich
sag's erstmal ein bild worden auf dem
planeten haben deswegen glaube ich es
ist wichtig dass wir jetzt gerade auf
instagram leute sehen die als vorbild
für eine ganz ganz viele menschen auch
hier zeigen hey ich bin dick und ich
stehe dazu oder die einfach sagen ich
esse so viel ich will und ich stehe dazu
ich glaube intuitives essen ist etwas
was wir neu und unbedingt erlernen
müssen ich mich können was du kennst ja
meine mutter ist 80 ja- und meine mutter
ist tatsächlich auch die als wenn ich
habe so lange diät gemacht in meinem
leben und das ist so dumm von mir ich
sage auch immer irgendwie wenn ich jetzt
nicht so viel geredet hätte ich wäre
vielleicht bundespräsidentin
entschuldigung ich finde der psychologe
ich finde den gedanken gut und ich
glaube ich wünsche mir eine gesellschaft
wo jeder sich wohlfühlt mit seinen
körper aber es gibt leute die sich nicht
wohl fühlen also ich zum beispiel habe
meinen besten jahren erlebt dass ich 20
kilo weniger war und ich bin gerade auf
die jetzt weil ich mich nicht wohl fühle
in meinen körper ich will was machen ich
will mich bewege bronze nach schlanker
werden will schlanker werden genau danke
wird im kopf schütteln es geht darum
wohl ich nicht wohl damit und ja ich
will dass kinder lernen zu essen viele
das essen zu zelebrieren das mit den
familien zu machen nicht irgendwie alles
schuldgefühle entwickelt sind was ist
aber wir haben auch auf der unterseite
andere probleme die driften nicht nur
frauen die trifft vor allem männer die
luft auch männer in mein alter die nicht
aufhören können zu essen die
irgendwelche traurigkeit und depression
mit essen kombinieren und das ist
natürlich auch ungesund oder wie viel
zucker wie pro tag essen und wie viel
der süßigkeiten und sachen die wir
einkaufen und haben 1000 schädlichen
stoffe dabei das sind alle faktoren wie
man auch mitdenken soll aber ich geb dir
absolut recht ich wünsche mir dass die
leute wohlfühlen wie sie sind und sich
lernen sich zu lieben ich habe übrigens
ich habe ja sendung moderierte ecke der
track china und ich habe ganz viele
anfeindungen dafür bekommen nach dem
motto mika warum tust du dir das an du
bist so ein ordentliches mädchen
die bahn habe die waren komplett nackt
besonders wer das nicht mag wir hatten
auch ein rentner runde
die war sehr gut aber das glaube live
aber
was sie was ich da so interessant und so
spannend daran fand war dass man seit
nach einer sehr langen zeit wann habe
ich damit angefangen habe das war 2017
zum ersten mal im fernsehen in hd mit
poren und fusseln am penis leute gesehen
hat die man also ohne filter ohne
irgendetwas und das war so schön
und so relax und was wir nämlich immer
sehen was wir für vorbilder vor bekommen
sind die geschönte version von allem
wenn ich jetzt gerade waren ja
olympischen spielen dann wird alles
mögliche kommen kommuniziert von den
athletinnen und athleten und also mehr
effekt olympische athleten du bist ja
die sind wenn sie bei olympia antreten
sind die top note von dem wo auch sie
vier jahre lang hin trainiert hauser die
deutschen athleten in diesem jahr zum
großteil aber
da sind mit ihm die sind toll ich die
sind dann und ab und das sind dann die
vorbilder für ganz viele leute wie auch
für dich natürlich fühlst du dich unwohl
warum niemand ist normal und natürlich
denn alles was du sieht das ist will das
länger psychologie nennt sich das upload
comparison wenn alles was du siehst du
vergleichst dich ja nicht mit leuten die
du slightly beschissener findet als ich
selber da wird es aber spannend aber die
entscheidung war nicht das was ich mache
ja nicht jeden tag sondern es kommen für
sind in meinem leben wo ich entscheide
okay ich will es anders essen und die
lockdown situation hat ja uns alle dazu
gebracht dicker zu werden und viel zu
kochen zu hause also allem dass alle
wird immer streichen ja doch ich neige
dazu ja polemisch zu sein das haben auch
andere sagen aber viele leute haben
gekocht und haben gegessen das auch
schön und in ordnung aber ich fühle mich
nicht wohl und frau es geht nicht nur um
die kilos es geht um die fähigkeit um
die sportlichkeit es geht um müdigkeit
es geht um gesund sein es geht um die
werte die man beim blutes bekommt und
das sind faktoren die man an
ich glaube wir müssen unterscheiden
zwischen diät das heißt ich mache er
drei jahre lang in haft ist um ein ideal
zu entsprechen das andere und das ist
ein wahnsinnig wichtiges thema über das
man ganz wie reden sollten ist gesunder
ernährung vernünftige ernährung
gesundheit ich finde die gegenüber
gesagt hat was mit sich zu tun und er
weiß also was was etwas unnatürliches
ich verzichte auf viel damit ich
irgendwo hinkommen das sagte schild
die wussten die jetzt machen damit sie
gesund werden dass nicht die absolute
ausnahme also das was ganz verschiedene
sachen du redest über das was jeder
mensch mit sich aus trägt auch männer
ständig das ist der kampf um die frage
was es sich heute was es sich jetzt ist
das nicht zu viel ist das nicht so fett
ist das nicht zu süß und das ist aber
das tut jeder mensch das ist aber nichts
neues oder nichts außergewöhnliches und
vor allem nichts perverses mich ich
frage mich immer wieder schon seit
langer zeit wer schafft eigentlich wer
baut diese vorbilder auf den frauen
nacheifern wenn sie sich zu tode hungern
sind das sind dass männer dass frauen
bei welche interessen stehen dahinter
ist dass die modeindustrie ist das sind
das andere industrie überhaupt kommt das
aus der industrie oder ob man das wetter
heute wo ja ja ja ja woher kommen die
dann gut das liegt natürlich sehen da
aber woher kommt ihr mächtig ganz kurz
welche bilder wären da gezeichnet von
wcc ja ja aber man darf eines nicht
einmal ganz kurz in der unterscheidung
machen ich bin auch total gegen die
filter ich bin da komplett beiden
mädchen filtern sich auch so furchtbar
dass man sie gar nicht mehr
wiedererkennt und hunger an sich runter
ich bin ja komplett bei dir weiß ich nur
meine finger weil du gerade vor wieder
angesprochen hast zum beispiel gisele
bündchen ist es ihr job trainiert zu
sein das heißt sie trainiert dann jeden
tag sechs stunden ist ihren job und ich
weiß jetzt es in der ausstellung zum
thema vorbilder in düsseldorf da waren
die supermodels der 90er jahre und da
fand ich claudia schiffer und alle fand
ich schon die bahn hat in ihrer in ihrer
disziplin waren sie halt die schönsten
der welt und die waren wir uns auch
nicht so ab wie magisch langweiligste
frau dadurch dass er tag sagen wir
müssen uns alle an nicht so crawford
warum sollte ich nicht eingetroffen sind
da muss man sich schon mal wenn das der
job ist dann ist es natürlich klar dass
gisele bündchen jetzt mehr zeit darauf
jeden tag verwendet auf ihr auf ihren
körper als jetzt zum beispiel andere ich
finde das ist ein ganz schmaler grat und
jetzt das zweite punkt ist warum man ist
oft so dünn sein die die gruppe gibt es
nicht auch ich lese immer öfter auf
instagram ich war dafür noch gar nicht
so sensibilisiert das extrem dünne
mädchen schreien hört auf mich zu
schämen
15 sind und nicht zu nehmen und dann von
allen hat also dieses bodyshaping geht
wohl mittlerweile in beide richtungen
auch deswegen so gut weil mainz diät
mager so das ist alles super schwierig
ist komplex
das ist wirklich blöd man kann da
irgendwie nicht einmal darüber sprechen
was uns sage ist dass unser körper ist
eine ganz super intelligente maschine
die es schon seit millionen von jahren
geschafft hat uns immer bis ans
lebensende zu bringen so und wir
schaffen auf aber mit unserer und ross
antony den wildschweinen
mit unserer kopf intelligenzen durch uns
oder mit künstlichen intelligenz manche
machen ja auch die per app
und dahin zu bringen dieses leben
künstlich zu verkürzen ja und ich sag
nicht man sollte kann
intuitives essen finde ich ist ein ganz
großartiges thema weil da plötzlich
wieder darauf so viel hunger habe ich so
viel habe ich nicht aber dicke menschen
sind ja jetzt nicht per se diejenigen
die am meisten essen dünne menschen sind
ja nicht versiegt diejenigen die am
wenigsten so da braucht man nicht nach
bürgel fallschirm da braucht man nicht
einmal so drüber sprechen auch dunja im
regelfall sage ich weiß nicht was die
regel ist aber ich glaube das was ganz
ganz schwierig ist da jemanden die
autonomie weg nehmen zu wollen ich
glaube dass man selbst zwar wirklich die
verantwortung übernehmen sollte dafür
was man essen möchte und was man nicht
essen möchte und das ist nämlich auch
zum beispiel bei krone und sowas ein
thema familienessen in unseren kulturen
auch sehr groß wir dürfen ja noch nicht
mal nein sagen und dass mich ein punkt
um den kreis zu schließen da sind wir
wieder beim thema schule das erwachen
die nach der schule mann und ernährung
in der schule geben also sondern die
kinder müssen auch angeführt hat was ist
im jahr durch vorbilder von heide sagen
auch keine antwort liegt und ich hab das
von noch nie
von einer frauen antwort auf diese frage
ich kann es dir aber das wunder waren
das die männer ganz eindeutig gehen auch
nicht
die haben gehört dass niemand weiß was
das ist ganz toll aber jetzt sind es
mittlerweile auch die frauen und was
seitdem passiert der sabotage können
väter werden
[Applaus]
[Musik]